welcome to this video playing hmm psych
Martin from Turkey about 2,200 rated
displaying the Queens gambit accepted
yeah I don't really know a good line
against it especially not so with knight
on f3 yeah I quite often play check
player check this variation it's a yeah
it's more dangerous than it looks which
is some yeah well not much it doesn't
look very dangerous at all but done well
it's certainly a playable option let's
continue to develop quite often black
players an underestimate whites play
here and then you in fact get something
let's see groups you one let's say you
know where does he do now if he goes
back here play Bishop e3 night Bishop d6
also night see for nerds it's slightly
uncomfortable for black nothing serious
but he needs to be cautious b6 just
hangs a six where's he going maybe
before but then a three before comes
with tempo and now that's maybe a slight
pool format based on this somewhat
uncomfortable King position on his
heaven
yeah well I this this I thought looks
shaky early because of Bishop a three
but maybe maybe it's not ever not a big
deal
what about a three is going 95 here
hmm it's probably not not too great okay
let's do that yeah my intention was
after Bishop move to play 95 but i
forgot that he's got Bishop f4 hmm hmm
yeah that's a bit that's not good
yeah walking then I don't have anything
at all I thought maybe 95 units 3338 or
something but even that is not nothing
special but here I am does this move
just just it's just okay look like now I
can treat a trade on c8 playbooks you
one just trade everything down but the
allah khair c'mon let's play the same
game I can take or t4 even isolate my
pawn now this is a bad game yeah this is
something I would really consider if I
was like in this position White's Bishop
on c1 doesn't look like a great piece
after taking yeah okay I should
shouldn't be enough in serious danger
but Bishop takes d4 at least unbalances
the position of it oh no is going for
that such a really fancy move not sure
what it is doing really okay looks like
it just develops me
I mean not like it like it's in trouble
or anything but it didn't really expect
neither form what is he doing taking
Knight c3 on I don't know it's good on a
three anyway
no III c 5 would be would be nice but
okay Bishop b5 at least prevented
prevented the King from activation and
93 is not on interesting
and yeah interesting claim that's a real
problem my king is not it's not helping
yeah if I take on d5 people take with
the bishop and Karen yeah Black is just
somewhat better here
yeah not not comfortable at all
I'm i hope that this serve helps to
helps to to get off some pressure I know
but after takes I can take and get to an
opposite Kellogg bishop sending check
this should be a rather George 53
seconds
yeah I'm always attacking the f6 pawn
this is this will be very difficult for
black Joe to make any progress yeah okay
this is a dead position really draw
Alfred corral Alfred q is declining a
draw you you know if I even have more
time it doesn't even have an extra bone
don't understand what's going on here
growl our third check the sky is hiding
a draw yeah I don't understand what he's
doing he's probably thinking that is
drawn what I I assemblies need to stop
about finding an irrational what people
are doing maybe he thought you would win
on time by pre moving quicker in a pond
down endgame but then you allowed the
simple repetition I really don't know
what's going on yeah it's probably I
mean what really had nothing
here I think it looks like there should
be something in this position but I
really didn't I really couldn't couldn't
make any headway the computer recommends
g3 with some play for Wyatt g3 are
covering F for such fe4 available it's a
gap not to move that cross my mind what
I really forgot us about Bishop a for a
bit bit embarrassing or forgot i tend to
use those words forgot and over look
like like being the same which of course
is not true i overlooked this Bishop a
for possibility and this just makes it
very very simple very simple for
blackity check yeah this is somewhat
strange but ok it's nothing nothing
serious happening and Ti over the
computer prefers black but I don't think
I should be in any substantial danger
yeah well I didn't understand the end at
all the three times declining the draw
but it was funny at least thanks for
watching